oh yeah
this will be why
because yeah you invested because you go
[Music]
so you have invested you've invested not
in this life not really not and you have
to negate that yeah to deny the never
went then take that with you somebody to
dinner
yeah he went to the then this happen
again he uses for sitting then they saw
a man come into the street and we saw
the man in distress is upset is no
special events in adobo sauce from why
so stressful
he said I owe a man some money and if we
didn't meet not hard time so I said if I
had the money I would pay for myself
yeah so I just working off of once the
house is evaluated god I can't invest it
he said I
[Music]
yeah so yeah he is walk-in and these are
beautiful these are beautiful things but
what is it we make the religion so
superficial that system yeah how many
relations go on
etc which is okay that's it and
personally when I marry me to see
mistake and what are the mistakes I make
it very clear
we seriously you instruct your mama boom
you don't wanna beat your wife
nothing do you come outside before and
the answer that's why I say this because
we need to understand no a sponsor don't
speak tonight
300 yes I walk around this book under
mine like this this is what you mean in
religion you know and in our system we
have a gamma brings about
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah like do you understand the
magnitude of what you see oh this person
is innovator what do you mean by
performance one of the seven issues with
about to fire and it's come to the point
where Robert the reason I mention this
is because you at this age or 19 20 22
23 properly you need to concentrate on
defending yourself do not concern
yourself with this one bathroom etc
basically
but if you go what
[Music]
so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but don't
judge recently because then you do
[Music]
so each of the religion is more because
in that box
inshallah welcome your duty so sauna and
goats go study in Shaba respect your
teachers etc that even mean here is it
happening as we know somehow but we need
to always respect people courage
Oh easy that's what we feel whatever
before I don't talk about I don't know
yeah sure why this we will give you that
night yes yes just because you are a
mutual and you study completely new
company and star no it should be that if
that's me complete you know that was not
a majority that this fabulous